so I get through that dinner right I
only got one cube of butter I needed one
more but what the hell first you're up
there
fast forward I win my second Cy Young
back to back back in the penguin suit
here we go now I'm popping my feeling
good I'm on Ted how you doing mick how
you doing hey Rocky yeah I'm first
feeling I'm feeling it talking away here
comes the same guy same friends Tony
Super Mario looks like Super Mario Bros
he goes by me and and I'm like hold on
guys hey I said hold up man hold up
minute he just gave me one I need
another cube of butter that's all I'm
looking for for my baked potato you know
just come on so I'm talking I see him
come on my guy and here he comes again I
I said dude stop I said I've been trying
to get you for 10 minutes my my stuff's
getting cold up here I said all I'm
trying to do is get another Cube I said
you know who I am right he goes oh yeah
I know who you are I go good I said I'm
trying to get some butter he goes
evidently you don't know who I am I go I
don't he goes I'm in charge of the
butter
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]